Ah, the holidays,
time of cheer and joy.
And aggressive
driving and road rage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Everyone, I'm Lacy.
I'm Tres, and the
holidays are stressful.
A study by State Farm Insurance
surveyed 1,000 drivers
and found that the
holidays suck for driving.
According to the results,
aggressive driving
spikes during the holidays
with 64% of second drivers
experiencing aggressive
driving six times or more
during the season.
Plus, almost half admit
they drive like jerks too.
The National Highway Traffic
Safety Administration
says that aggressive driving
means improper lane changing,
tailgating, speeding.
And though cutting
people off, being a dick,
and trying to steal
parking spaces
were not in their metrics, they
did show up in the surveys,
as well as not
using turn signals.
If you think about
it, of course it's
super rude to cut someone off.
But I also get
irrationally mad about it.
I'm like, are you
kidding me [BLEEP]?
What the [BLEEP] are you doing?
And I'm not alone.
90% of drivers admit to
seeing red on the road.
Yea, and psychologists note that
aggressive driving is portrayed
in movies and films as
exciting, so like lane changes
that are really fast and
acceleration and car chases.
This causes people to get into
heightened emotional states
when we're driving.
And experts goes as far as
to say as we're actually
emotionally impaired when
we're behind the wheel.
There's a lot
going on around us.
And there's a lot of
stress in operating
these kind of giant machine.
And AAA says humans
are territorial.
So we think of cars
as our territory.
And we want to protect them.
So we'll take it personally
when someone starts frontin'.
Psychologists also
agree that cars
are kind of an
extension of our ego.
Which makes sense.
When I'm alone in a car,
it's an extension of me,
and it gives me the
all important control.
So during the holidays,
it's even more pronounced,
presents to buy,
parties to attend,
travel to book, food
prepared, guests
to deal with, family,
friends, vacation time, work.
It's a lot to deal with.
So that sense of control
plus our everyday stressors
can cause rapid
release of anger when
something unexpected happens.
It's just a car man.
But some personalities
do gravitate
toward road aggression.
And even a disorder
affecting 7.3% of adults
called intermittent
explosive disorder,
which sounds exactly
like what is.
Studies show that's
humans crave violence,
and when we're emotionally
impaired and driving,
our more irrational
mind can react
to these crazy
situations, which does not
seem promising for us Lacy.
Other than self
driving cars, I'm
not sure what we're going to do.
Take a tip from
the professionals.
They advise road ragers
to get enough sleep,
don't listen to
aggressive music.
Keep in mind everyone
makes mistakes, even you.
Don't get me wrong.
You're perfect in every
way, except when you aren't.
So play nice.
And when someone's aggressive,
don't take it personally.
Let it go.
And ignore it.
I give people a
thumbs up actually
on the road, and a big old
smile when they're jerks.
So do you guys get road rage?
Tell us about how you
cope in the comments
below and subscribe, or
else we'll run you over.
Yeah, with the car
that I totally have.
We'll see you next
time on DNews.